well boy it's Tuesday time balls using I
guess so huh I guess it could be
technical to say when there's new
content and updates there's a new new
deal see out this one's free right Eric
they're always free my friend well thank
you for enlightening me on that one
Rob alright so yeah we're gonna be
checking out operation frontier shield
and there's a lot of patch notes with
this one I think one of the bigger ones
is that there's a new kind of like co-op
horde mode essentially correct that
hasn't been in titanfall - I think there
was kind of like a horde mode in
titanfall 1 in 1 yeah yeah it was one of
the last if I have the last update they
had for that game and here yeah it's
it's here we're gonna check it out I
just played a quick second of it make
sure that it was running and it is and
this is early on ps4 I don't think it's
has been released yet on PC or Xbox one
so stay tuned we'll both wear all
platforms we'll roll out today of the
tweets it's supposed to be out today
again as Rob mentioned it's out a little
early on ps4 so you can actually go play
it but I would suggest watching us and
playing at the same time obviously
currently Rob is looking through some of
the new Warpaint's the for the guns as
well as there will be some for the
Titans these ones do cost a little bit
of money right do you know they're they
are expensive um I purchased purchased
just this these Warpaint's because you
know you got to make your own call I
think these are like I will double check
my think they're like five dollars each
which is yeah pretty steep for one
they're called elite war paints but like
I for one always use the Eva always use
all together so like I kind of just made
the call like alright I'm just gonna do
it they bought them all or dependence by
the one I bought them off for five
dollars
oh okay so the foot there's a bundle too
which is cool the button then the plus
if you see the bottom there is that they
do they do bump up the merits you take
and 2% chance Peron for completion of
match yeah it's so it's just like expert
aloneness is or XP increase if you have
those on come in those high titans there
are there
Warpaint's for the Titans but like these
don't do much for me I mean I more of
the gun I'm a I'm a North Star main
sometimes a scorch scorch looks cool but
I don't know who must been I don't know
I'm not gonna do this so again you're
spending another potentially twenty five
or five dollars with that one Titan you
really like for me it's like if you play
a lot you're probably gonna be picking
like you know the guns or the the Titans
you're you're gonna use the most
obviously right so right just want to
say thank you guys for tuning in yeah on
twitch and YouTube and on GameSpot me
and Rob here will be reading the chat
checking you guys out chatting with you
guys obviously if you guys haven't
subscribed or followed us already
we obviously like that if you guys could
so that you guys could get informed it
when we go alive with these fun live
streams we do them every day at 11 a.m.
that's right and Rob loves titanfall 2
so expect more 10 fall to coverage as we
go along
yeah cuz it's a like and it helps me
cover this game work because you know
there are so many games to play nowadays
and this one's you know it's a little
old but it's still keeping fresh yeah so
fresh we're gonna primarily on this
stream we're primarily gonna do the
horde mode but we'll probably check out
the two new maps I'll run through some
of the patch notes there's a lot of
passion notes there's been some
balancing no leaks as well the two new
maps one new map is called rise the
other one is a new live fire map called
Township oh and this is gonna work out
great new mode frontier defense there's
an easy mode I guess is what I selected
just to get in one quicker but this is
on the new map rise which is from the
last game cool yeah
is the coop way basis drop the game
audio to turn a bit and happy birthday
to Isaac I see you there bud
hope you guys ik hope you're not just
linings margarita aka Nick marker you
know in the editing pit outside there
woo get hype
Oh we'll need it probably not
don't worry alfredo we're getting to the
Horde mode just want to show off we're
in it we're paints real quick oh look at
this warp America alternators oh yeah
here we go oh you want a little more
I'll give you a little more oh yeah I
remember this map oh yeah this way too
much nightfall too but this was a
classic this was a classic because you
could like legitimately never touch the
ground just because the map design a lot
of corridors and such so this is way
based so I believe there are oh yeah
five waves I'm sure they ramped up
probably the last one is like with heavy
Titans but here's the first one I have
not played this all the way through so
we'll see so yeah you're all you know if
the war paints are limited I know I can
I've read that the bundle is only
available until the 28th at least for
the war weapon war paints
do you know if the titan war paints are
also like a limited-time kind of thing
yeah I think oh Jesus yeah I believe the
tide of war paints are limited gotcha so
yeah if you see something you like you
probably want to scoop it up if you can
and the bundle is a little bit cheaper
obviously because you get them all for a
lower price because otherwise our $4.99
each yeah yeah sorry I cut you off
talking about your alternator your hot
alternate oh there's not much to it this
is one of my favorite guns I but I do
think the the the Titan Warpaint's lasts
till the 28th of next month I'm Marcus
yep don't say that limited edition okay
goodbye until 8:28 I probably should
have look used my eyes there but I was
watching you play this new horde co-op
mode this is kind of the first time for
the most part that you kind of run
through this so we'll see how it goes
it's about five waves right that's what
says right there yeah looks like they
all work so you're defending your guy
wanna pour some what is it it's called
something harvester and it looks like
dudes already got to it we were kind of
spread out a little too far there we go
jor-el Dupree I see you in the chat
thank you for tuning in there's a shout
out to gamertag sings super excited for
this new mode love frontier defense on
tf1 yeah
so pretty stoked here in the office Mike
was playing outside he kind of popped in
like yeah I had to go to appointment
he's like dude pretty good this is
pretty good
Eddie tanker this is a new PvE co-op
horde mode in titanfall 2 that got
released today it's currently out on
PlayStation 4
I think it's been out in Europe and
Australia a little bit ahead of you know
obviously us here in the States but
we're now playing on ps4 in the u.s.
shield run into that harvester yeah
those guys stalkers they take little
ability and well although give it a
little more damage when they explode so
currently just so you guys know we are
playing on easy just to get into a game
faster will obviously do the normal mode
after this it's a good way to kind of
feel out how hard this mode is you know
and it looked like there was a four
tiers of modes to that we're locked for
Rob probably because he has to finish
like normal regular right regular mode
for what imagine he's like laying
regular yeah and then and then a hard
mode and then the LA speed master I
think there's also an insane difficulty
one but that's like they said it's like
separate from those four difficulties
like you have to go somewhere else I
don't know I would imagine you have to
defeat master mode first I didn't see it
anywhere so like another special like
unlock after yeah so we're still on wave
one yeah so despite wave or five waves
these are kind of taking a while and you
had to deal with a Titan earlier as well
as you know some of these grunts and
inspectors yeah and it looks like the
harvester here like you'll see the bar
the health bar kind of ticked down but
it does look like it regenerates
so you can expect these waves getting so
overwhelming mines my believe for it's
like yeah you can't stop that okay can't
stop the amount of damage it's receiving
you'll probably have to you know
would any well like every horde mode
you're gonna have to really learn this
kind of like the Swan points and where
things are coming from and then like
have almost like equal distribution of
your teammates so that you guys kind of
like cover you know left and right
obviously depending on the map of course
so and it looks like we lost one of our
teammates also is he like Garn or like
DC or dead mm-hmm
he looks like he's out oh he's back I
don't know what oh so so it's a
cool-down so he's coming in now on a
dropship I think oh okay so you can't so
there might not be like a revive then
you might have to actually like wait it
out and what are you using the regen
kind of perk the perk I'm using is stem
I haven't gonna use it much I'm more of
a cloak yeah I know you are I can switch
to that at some point I get a lot of lag
here I guess I imagine a lot of people
are trying to get on you know so your
should be able to like buy stuff I don't
know when you do with them maybe yeah
yeah I saw a pink behind the harvester
all right so wait break between waves
you can change your loadout purchase
army items play play sentry turrets so
you're right there you go just have to
finish the way so kind of spend out that
moolah alright got that money yep okay
North Star that's a risk Armory here
alright well we already hi ant weapons
shield boost for the harvest sentry
turrets nuke rodeo arc trap
all right I'll do one of those yeah
there's also like apparently a new Titan
progression in the frontier defense
called the aegis ranks earth earn a kiss
ranks by completing matches of frontier
defense
aigis ranks can unlock powerful upgrades
for your Titans helping you succeed at
higher difficulty levels for for now
these ranks will only apply to a
frontier defense and I'm apps for this
dis horde mode yeah then they'll roll
out more down the road probably next
update and yeah the aegis ranks are
really interesting so we were looking at
them like for the moment they only
pertain to this mode this co-op mode but
like you kind of level up your the
ability to unlock these abilities and
the last one is I believe for like
scorch for instance it's um your your
traps that you set your incendiary traps
they'll explode after you drop them
you're just big or another one is this
slow this fiery on this gun is really
slow as you can see you can fire three
without having to reload oh wow yeah so
it's like really big upgrades that will
definitely like change times or ask
Allah and so what's interesting is like
I think they're gonna like try it out
and then you know ultimately a lot of
like yeah and see how it plays out a lot
of lag i hot ping yeah the only thing I
could offer you is we could try another
port on the other side of the room but
then we have to disconnect it for a hot
second which I feel like we had to do
last
yeah we did see look at this he should
have been dead
so that's your call Rob we can do that
if you want well I'm not doing fairly
here a necromancer is getting a hot ps4
maintenance update oh I didn't know what
fortunate but maybe he just hasn't
turned on his ps4 / ok software update
what do you what did you want to do we
got a little Titan challenge let's try
the playable are you I mean it's it's
alright so yeah there's also a bunch of
balance tweaks I can talk about some of
those later when we kind of play some of
the multiplayer this do you know if the
titan balances also affect this mode so
like let's say for yeah oh yes oh yeah
they're all around yeah scorch I'm
playing he had the biggest nerve there
oh no the biggest pop-ups oh yeah I will
read through some of them squash will
now have one - charge within 1/10 I can
pull down firewalls whiff is been
increased you get Sports kits wildfire
our launcher now increases the direct
hit damage of the thermite launcher
still increases the amount of these
spread oh this is what it's like if you
were dead
apparently this ping is ridiculous so do
you want to back out yeah
so it couldn't even eject I'm gonna
quickly go to our camera and I'm gonna
tell Rob to take you see that great
Ethernet unplug it down there and then
plug it into the gray Ethernet that's
across the room so ya minor technical
difficulties we do apologize yeah you
gotta unplug well I can do it
hang in there last time we did it took
not long at all
play through YouTube copy that copy that
so yeah apologies alright hopefully
that's better
apologies for that we'll get back into
the game here but yeah we're checking
out the horde mode he had some bad lag
there so we just exited so that we could
get back into it hopefully here in a
second yeah but yeah new operation
operation frontier shield DLC out now on
ps4 you could play that looks like we're
hopefully back in and hopefully is
connectivity go aren't you go regular I
agree
just get anyone easy no I didn't are you
didn't okay now I turned off so the new
like they did this they rolled out this
new kind of menu system we can search
for either or okay that's pretty cool
yeah so I'm just looking at regular here
cool I finished that scorch list Oh
score so you look at all these aegis
drinks here so yeah oh cool
igniting travel triggers an initial
explosions three shots Mac shields
increased thermite damages increase
multiplier for your core abilities
they're all really interesting like it's
gonna take you a while though it looks
like 20 yeah that's that's sometime
[Music]
Northstars my favorite yeah two of these
things Oh to cluster missiles do you
what that means business business as
usual it's I think mr. Yenter
I think it's only online right
I don't think there's like a I don't
think there's a key stop I'm just trying
to get it centered here's what's up
there's why you know split screen right
now there's never this came 1.5 k is
nothing for me I have to deal with three
K ping says her halo Fang
so he says step up your game stop
complaining about life that makes sense
did you see that ping double your ping
and he's fine
so I'm in stirone okay yeah most games
nowadays don't have split-screen that's
probably pretty accurate Pokemon to
zapper and then YouTube chat so this is
a new skin for the shotgun my favorite
can't really see it's got like like a
nice warthog jock teeth scent mouth on
the front yeah with like a long tongue
[Music]
alright so this is normal right we're
playing normal now yes alright
Coolio mixing LOL finally downloading
for Xbox one so it sounds like it's also
available on Xbox one which is pretty
cool thank you guys again for tuning in
and staying with us as we gone through
that little bit of Internet
but we are good now hopefully yeah it's
pretty good is uh it says good actually
says good on the paint which literally
says good I agree
bong bong almost like chief spelled
Rambam chief six six six this game was
very underrated I think Rob could attest
to that I think so I think I think you
know we've talked about it then people
the most part no it had you know it had
a kind of a tight window of release yeah
in between the big two players so not
many people really knew about it yeah do
you it's funny you mentioned that
because someone earlier in chat said you
know like this is such a good game but
it had like kind of like a poor release
timing like it just like came out at
like as you mentioned between two other
big games oh that's new as to why that
was
damn there was a cloak drone I've never
seen that before they added that that's
completely new it was like yeah we got
it was cloaking a Reaper so yeah these
guys are really common so here it is
that's that's a completely new dude I've
never seen in my life
cool so like we're already seeing some
differences between like new and easy
and normal as well as new enemy types in
the game I don't know yeah pokemons Zoo
zapper I don't know if they said that
battlefield 1 in cod necessarily
squashed it but it definitely made it a
lot harder to compete especially since
it is in the PSP it's slightly different
I mean yeah like the idea the point
being that like oh I going for a sci-fi
shooter or like an old-school shooter
like most people know a cod yeah then
titanfall like that's something that I
was surprised when it came out with the
the release date though for this game
because I was like man like there's no
way they could just hold off to like you
know good month like that worried yeah
but you know it's always like that
discussion of okay you know q4 it's like
obviously a big time for people to be
spending money cuz like you're nearing
Christmas and all that stuff so that's
why I think a lot of games come out in
q4 because you know that's like windy
quarterly spend is happening speak and
people have been saving up for the year
whereas like February everyone spent
their money on Christmas they bought
their gifts chances are you know you
might have a harder time but I don't
know it so it's nice to have some of
those games that come out in February
like I think Mineo came out in February
it was like a surprise game that people
ended up really enjoying so yeah it's
interesting I mean I'm sure it's tough
there's a lot of things that we don't
know but on a very base level that's
what I think is part of the reason for
sure so we'll see if there's any more
new enemies that that cloak drone was
pretty cool seems like you have to kill
that guy really to kind of really engage
and like whatever it close yeah he was
cloaking like a Reaper and those guys
have been definitely beefed up from last
update so they're tough they're really
hard to kill what you want to go are you
mean now Northstar yeah my man BAE
you know I have the exact same sweet
skin
yeah picnic definitely agree with you
he's hoping for another game because
Tybalt's who did such a good job with a
single player and the multiplayer and
guess what now we even have co-op oh I
wasn't ready Duff that's why like let's
go we got some we got some hot
aigis ranks we gots to be getting and
you're holding us back yeah I feel bad
hey man new the mode dude no I'm new
here near your green and speaking of new
mortar Titans that just flashed the top
right oh yeah these guys are different
so they're Titans that they have like
motor abilities all right I think I
should be hunting him down bad shot
just aa lot of cloak drones he says I
got a target over here here we go
okay so you're dealing with enemy times
as well it's prequel yeah I think that
like it's awesome to see multiplayer
games at even modes it's like the same
with when overwatch kind of did their
junk in Stein's revenge thing I think
it's like a game type that's it's pretty
needed in some of these very competitive
type co-op
I'm sorry competitive type multiplayer
games it's nice to have like a co-op
mode that you can kind of just play
against the the AI
yeah totally upon the AI it's it's
almost like a by means of like taking it
easy you know like all right like I'm
not gonna like yeah I'm getting it
working multiplayer yeah yeah totally
especially for people who like maybe
fell off for that same reason titanfall
yeah cuz like you're just like oh well
it's that multiplayer grind and some
people you know just they don't enjoy
the competitive multiplayer like that's
just not their thing they probably
really enjoyed the single-player game
right exactly ball which luckily they
include it this time around good on them
obviously and like it's good to have
like a like a horde mode
I guess look at that it was close I was
champ close but it's also good I guess
you can kill those without
Jones obviously yeah oh [ __ ] there's
something someone here
you're like Northstars good here to like
get up here oh [ __ ]
so baby boy six seven six nine oh crap
mortar Titans yeah I haven't seen really
one yet I'm trying to look for it maybe
that's an indicator of it oh that's like
a mortar coming down right or maybe the
mortar a little bomb
yeah I'm still trying to understand
these prompts dad okay Nepal two is my
favorite anime mecha anime I like it
oh those are them so those are order
spectres up so it'll start off with
mortars for lower enemies is what I'm
gathering and then by the end of it big
times might be a wielding mortars okay
so like it'll like be harder to take
them down obviously right and yeah this
is wave two right this is pretty fun
yeah picnic also another good point it's
cool how co-op now it's highs in the
multiplayer so people who are not
necessarily as good at like normal like
competitive multiplayer can also unlock
stuff in co-op
we got here shut up and lose eighty
eight I don't believe you can split
screen this unfortunately I believe it's
just online which is just kind of like
the norm now it was like the biggest
gripe in like halo right oh that was
huge because I'm kind of curious if like
we haven't heard word of like you know
the next Caleb I'm kind of curious if
they bring that mode back that couch
just a lot feel I think they will I
think or like will do something with
like the Scorpio or xbox one X right
yeah the whole you always told the
stories that like it was like you and
your brother is playing every time yeah
legendary oh [ __ ] it's already getting
real spicy see that's cuz I went so far
our mean a bunch of other guys did yeah
we always just play legendary right
split-screen and we couldn't do it that
time it's bust because they they said
they made the sacrifice for 60fps
because either that or split-screen or
30 frames for split screen which I would
have taken yeah people probably would
like or like they could've did something
we're like when it went is like you know
they could have done words like you go
to split screen and then it drops us 30
yea changes or something right like they
that's what you hear with splatoon like
you know there are ways to limit frame
rate for different certain areas like in
that hub area for splatoon that's like
30 frames and then the game is actually
at 60 crisp man seventh 7/7 there isn't
a mortar titan that's playable it's just
the enemies currently that it's a new
enemy type right right yeah EMC studio
we see you your name is Jeff apparently
really would appreciate stop stabbing
though but hi where's my Papa scorch
says the Sam Manila I should have
switched sapphire bucket welcome back
Juggalo Cesar the dune where we do
interact with chat glad you can tune in
and hang out with us appreciate it
what are your thoughts about monarch
Titan I think you got asked this last
time too but let's hear your thoughts on
monarch Titan
how do I use it hon how do I use arc
traps did you buy it oh there we get one
or did you only purchase one I got
something I only got one
okay where's my boy at umm monarch is
real hard to use i I gotta get back in
the monarch it's a very interesting
Titan right like in that light levels up
it levels up and when you get to that
like high level in game you're like a
beast however everyone wants you dead in
your earlier weaker stage is sort of
like you it's a really interesting type
of play where you're being really
conservative and you're just like
hanging back and taking moments but like
you also can't do that though you know
you can't be a scaredy cat the whole
game like you have to find your moments
and be just really conservative but it's
tough but really fun like you're okay
it's like a different Titan race a
different way of playing the Titan and
then like obviously finding that that
balance of you know finding a way to
survive and level of
and then once you level up beasting on
people essentially hey oh come on
sorry if I'm butchering that or come ,
Marshall asking do you like Ronin Ronin
is tough
I don't know here's a ronin for you I
don't I'm not good with Ronin I'm so not
and that's that's just something where I
like I've made the mistake almost I'm
just playing so much Northstar works
like every time I get a new Titan I just
like instinctively do those Northstar
moves and I just screw up memory yeah
like I have to like spend a lot of time
with it let you do executions and this
you can't for sure yeah the Sam Manila
asking how do you feel about the male
laner
did you read that one yet oh yeah so
melee lunch and melee hit frames changed
2.3 seconds from point two this will
help people firing weapons particulary
automatic weapons I'm intuitive shots in
before the lunge completes I'm into it
and then the lunge range has also been
reduced and non lunge at melee attack
ranges have been increased this will
help the cases where melee looks like it
should hit but doesn't actually connect
with the target oh yeah
let me rip that off yep yep I'm into it
because I actually did think that the
the melee was like a little o P and that
like like I whatever I would I would
enter a room some guy could just like
he'll be across the room and he would
lunge and I wouldn't even be able to get
a shot off like it's it's a shooting
game you should be able to shoot before
you like get a melee and melee should be
a last resort type thing always to me at
least cause baby commando lunch
let's go each their own oh man that was
that's the way to go I just recall like
how bad those moment were and like how I
always felt like oh like there's no way
he like actually melee to me before I
actually killed him and then the kill
cam would always show you like okay yeah
he did it but it I was like a latency
kind of thing yeah
damn dude this is getting hairy yeah
there's only wave three of five there's
a good fine though I think
harvester is she'll observe backup oh
good all right so that's thing you just
gotta like get those brakes executions
confirmed that's correct baby boy pit
pine DS man we're currently playing on
normal we probably ought to beat normal
to unlock the next difficulty we can
potentially try that if we can get
through this mode Thomas Olsen from
YouTube chat asking Rob what is your
favorite weapon Eve it was Eva and then
like a couple updates ago they like
nerfed it pretty heavily yeah as far as
range goes that was a beast lately it's
been the EPG I think last time we play
oh yeah yeah dude that like one shot
energy yeah that thing isn't real fun to
use it's fun to like lead and predict
where people are going to end up so you
can watch them explode alternator has
been the consistent favorite oh I can
change my loadout guys hi mister chilled
gamer says hi I love this channel thank
you for stopping by tuning in with us we
really appreciate it we love that you
guys are here hanging out with us
chatting with us asking those questions
how to sidearms feel says kassir unison
roach richard asking and i don't know
the answer this one maybe you do or
maybe chat does Richard and YouTube chat
asking do you still get standard
multiplayer unlocks through this mode
you know sir I was trying to see if I
could change mine okay you focus on that
I've asked once again sorry do you still
get standard multiplayer unlocks through
this mode standard multiplayer unlocks I
yeah oh like its credits cut yeah I
believe so I wouldn't yeah I would
imagine I think that's what someone had
mentioned in chat earlier kind of
alluding to that point which was like
that was a nice part of having this mode
- I think it was Nick pick or picnic
maybe that's why he calls himself a pig
but if he can get back in the chat and
tell us kind of like if that's true or
not that's great
we always appreciate you guys helping us
out we
to give you as much information as
possible but at the same time some of
you guys in chat are super knowledgeable
and always willing to share which is
awesome
yes sure
ps4 legend asking what is your favorite
DLC might be this one so far I think the
last one was pretty awesome
last one had this map were playing on
had that sick new execution it's good
question baby well these deals cease
I've been getting better and better I'd
say maybe this one so far or the last
one I think to answer your question
question ps4 legend I feel that robbed
each time a new DLC comes out basically
tells everyone in the office now sniff
now is definitely the time to come back
to titanfall so I feel like it's
probably whatever the new DLC is that's
coming out yes so yeah the quite the
answer is yes battle canyon asking does
each difficulty bring different sets of
rewards I don't know it showed that
earlier and I don't know if I've read
that in the past I stopped doing that
punching ticks yeah so I baby bar was
like that's the new meta you just to it
it's so dumb it's somewhat but it makes
me angry say hey tix I just want to
punch and just bring it
trying to look damn yo
I don't see anything specific to the
difficulties but maybe we can check it
out after we get through hopefully oh
that's a mortar okay so this is thing
all right so I'll see if I can get this
mortar oh he's doing it oh he's doing it
definitely I was a jerk he's like I
don't mind me just you know filling in
the back here Oh at least he they
stopped once yeah justjust engaging oh
your shields down
sure is that's not so hot there's
another mortar defending it though good
that sniper
all right shields going up that's good
I am the best sniper yeah crazy 99 I
think this is a good time to get in back
into yeah mentions Rob said every time
there's a DLC it's a good time to come
back but they can't adding a lot of good
free content this is like particularly
my kind of vibe I'm all about that PvE
by repetition
I am make it justice rains from above
sort of
sort of all right we backed up to 98 you
liar no that's the hell oh that's not
good Kamiya Marshall asking you rob
what is your feeling hi favorite pilot
bro
there you go I'd say I'd say it'd have
to go to cloak cloaks fun to cut out
mister cloak and then I would say stim
is great and then I would say I don't
know I think the one I would want I was
like your to go right yeah and I would
say the one I would really want a more
direct oh and um water guy damn I would
say the other one would be I like his
face shift where you just kind of blink
out of existence
come here Marshalls favorite is grapple
yeah well if the grapple is like the one
that you is like the Ronin were like I
need to like practice yeah it's one of
those things it's even like you just get
accustomed of really playing a couple of
your favorite you always say like I'm
gonna go try using you know Ronin and
then like you're like ah god I just got
work I should go back to North Star yeah
oh dang what's going on oh yeah exactly
you just gotta stick with it if you want
if you want to get good you just gotta
stick with that said class or tied me
just keep playing it and not finding
that hurting up resisting the tendency
to like go back to yeah you just kind of
have to stick with it just know that you
know there's gonna be so much some bad
times bad times it's gonna be good times
later yeah exact this makes perfect
yeah the other day there's a ronin who I
was a North Star in like this it was
windy situations look like I had full
health and this guy was such a beast he
was doomed right yeah and he was able to
do my time before me like took me out
did he's done the same for he did
everything right every move he did was a
direct counter and it was so impressive
I like message and I was like that was
absolutely incredible
because the thing you're going in with
such high like expectations are you know
when there's like yeah this guy's done
he's doomed it was pretty cool
j.vin chasing oh my god they really did
bring it it out this is amazing yeah
it's a pretty fun one to rob having a
lot of fun we're not wait five of normal
doing pretty good only two percent
damage I said ninety-eight percent
damage and I called the NPC a liar
earlier I apologized that was actually
how much health the harvester had stuff
oh right yeah yeah call you Maya got it
so I just got a harvester she'll boost
that should probably get us through this
final way
AJ did saying what pilot do you
recommend for this move are just say
you've been anything your tighten a lot
I feel like we have kind of like I need
to be in a way um well I can tell what
tighten I was just thinking about was I
think monarch would be actually really
great here because of how many Titans
there are and how dumb they are yes we
level up pretty
you'll love up pretty quick but one of
the the the of them like many abilities
of monarch is one is like when you do an
elimination on it to enemy Titan you
like to take their batter and you level
up so if you stall like how many
eliminations around like three already
like you can easily level up yeah you
should try that next round yeah I could
cool uh die Allah chose no be sorry I
really push it that laughing good luck
at the final round guys thank you oh we
all need it
Mythbusters 166 at YouTube chat saying I
just finished my first game and it was
intense intense this has been pretty
intense there any bonus are you killing
ship I guess it just stops dropping
drugs man see Josh cam at wall saying
just adds split-screen and I'll play the
game I'm sure there would be a lot more
people playing how do you feel about
split-screen nowadays I feel like every
time I've tried a split-screen game I
ghent weird it's kind of weird right
because like kind of been outdated to a
degree for shooters at least yeah I just
feel like it would open up a lot I think
just having the option would be nice I
don't know how much effort and like work
it takes to kind of get split screen
Indo game you know Anna means and then
the value of that at the end of the day
but you know there's a lot of you know I
don't know if it's the same as we when I
was younger and I was a kid but like you
know it was more likely that you know
your friend had one console and you had
another or something so you real
Padgett split screen yeah and maybe you
just don't have to now it is oh no you
okay this again real hair you know huh
yeah I definitely think so
so with all these new skins we even
really show those new Archer and you
Archer skin here so you're you're
currently cloak tight pilot right yeah
what's up McHale Scout the Scout rather
are we playing survival well no we are
currently playing the new co-op horde
mode that has come out as free DLC today
currently out on ps4 North America
that's where we're at obviously and then
it's also someone in chats that they're
also downloading it for Xbox one so that
gets out on the Xbox one to someone else
can confirm that possibly probably on
cpc's normally right behind ps4 Jesse
Alexander asking his tone a bad option
yeah people really like telling that's
the most popular title
it'd be good for here yeah I think I
think you'd want to stick to the medium
to have your chassis Titans like I don't
know about north sources
North Stars been pretty good as far as
actually picking off like those mortars
yeah I think he's definitely diversified
because one eye things I just noticed
forgot actually is that once you pick
your Titan and you start one these modes
you cannot change it ever rob mr. chill
gamer asking what is your favorite
execution I guess let's do pilot and
Titan okay I can answer this get on
pilot its inner pieces yeah I have a
equipted that's where you warp you phase
into someone's body matrix action yeah
and explode out yeah dr. Agent Smith
yeah and then I think the coolest hi
yeah you're right is a scorched prime
where he punches twice and then he does
is his poor building slams ground and
let the enemy Titans like just kiss me
rockets
I thought you were oh there we go guys
Sports over here but the new Titan or a
North Star prime is pretty good I have
that on right now I like how you're able
to like I like the is pretty dominant oh
here's a mortar here like this that's
that's the North Star Prime on the North
Star original chassis
oh no I I gotta go back the base oh no
oh you got 49% oh no no shield right now
I'm coming we may catch at will we make
it
what's the problem what's going so far
away right yeah like I mean walleston
why don't you has to kind of deal with
lay back yeah one of you guys has to
like deal with the mortars you know you
were still good because there's like two
mortar Titans obviously they're going to
town I think one of your guys one of
your buddies is dealing
or 45% Oh No
there's a lot of mortar top half oh you
know well they're going for the mortar
oh my god all right
how long till you get your Titan it's
gonna take a while okay
well you're not gonna have to hang back
use your archer get rid of some of these
pesky Titans that are trying to slowly
peck at the will be there's only eight
enemies okay
your Titans off oh my god there are so
many Titans are here but come on oh come
on come on come on don't move some of
them go for it boom boom boom
hello a Genco pinko poco that's your
name activate the shield please don't oh
my god yeah good cold uh Mac is back one
to 195
Swach ATS there get to the top bosses
Chris man seven seven seven we got this
we are good that that was a good call
Thank You Brandon the wolf also tell him
to see who's the head shield boost last
kill
nailed it up top
Oh mission come that was regular man so
yeah a lot of team what you want man
like I would want to play with
somebody's on two Mike's here
you know because I got it you reckon see
me like that whoo we did it Rob
great job look at those points okay okay
you got your homeland security you
definitely protected the fort
dude that guy did a lot of damage cases
for ever and most wave MVPs pretty good
pretty good
nice nice use the shield boost yeah
everyone shield boots ah do a 360
no-scope oh yeah all right next time
with so you want to try and monarch see
how that plays out yeah it won't play
out well in Titanic so we can try it
thank the Lord you saw yeah all right so
let's think here if I was saying okay
congratulations says dalla thank you
okay cool
margarita we were on rise the first time
it's a random there's five maps that can
be picked of which I'll tell you
Homestead forward base a code I war
games rise Blackwater now that was war
games hopefully we'll get you that hot
gameplay margarita mr. Nick margarita
thank you battlefront pro gaming for
telling us that it is indeed out on Xbox
as well thank you guys again for tuning
in I'm Eric that's Rob we are checking
out the new titanfall 2 DLC operation
frontier shield has a new four player
PvE co-op horde mode five waves and
butter blade saying liking the chat
interaction guys cropsy yep that's what
we're trying to do we appreciate you
guys being with us the 100 obviously
Jared arruda asking can you show me some
of those yeah he's just setting up his
uh monarch but he can show you some of
those agus is it am I saying that right
I think it's a just yeah aegis we can
see let's see okay well first I'll have
to go procure it should be out for Xbox
one as confirmed by a few people here in
chat so maybe try backing out of your
titanfall and seeing if you know that
updates it if that doesn't work I'd
always try resetting your console and
that might work as well Oh what what is
it
so the the aegis train for monarch is
one of these core upgrades that you need
like work towards you just start off you
just but that's it I guess rank 20 right
and do you know how much you've gained
we can check your your who I played I
played in North sir on one bar oh and I
got to - so now you have an upgrade do
you have - is it like a passive ability
like you just have it from now on yeah I
think it just has it so that's pretty
good these Saudi like explosive traps in
my opinion are like something that I
just don't care for for you know that's
how their minds yeah like that's awesome
and so the whole thing is like what
everyone's like kind of like biting
their nails on is they said in the patch
they said for now these ranks are in
just frontier defense so they could go
into normal like PvP which would be
absolutely bonkers
what's up Jaden Walker welcome to the
stream frontier defense good or bad says
rich boy pretty fun I think it's really
fun I think it would be better to play
with your buddies like most co-op oh so
you didn't unlock the next difficulty
level just from beating regular it seems
like oh you gotta get to rate agus rank
5 ok that makes fun any Titan so I
should be sticking to one Titan yeah you
want to do that no I won't get to 5 like
yeah by the time that happens
so um shot some monarch here or what you
might be scourge now I think monarch
would be cool here we could try to I'm
kind of curious to like if like well
we'll see here in a second playing
regular again if it if it varies at all
or if it's kind of the same because I
hopefully it it's not the same I you
know because otherwise it kind of does
get a little I don't think it gets a
little mundane because then it gets
predictable and that's when it kind of
becomes less fun in my opinion yeah but
you know if you're hanging out with your
buddies and whatnot that probably helps
a lot
Swann when I will answer for Rob his
favorites Titan is Northstar damn rent
what's up Jake e^x 98 welcome welcome
welcome
I'm putting on the new skins here oh
this one doesn't have it
favorite overwatch characters ask Miya
you did ask that earlier sorry we didn't
get to that I will go and say mine are
zenyatta May of course right May all day
and see her tank junk right or not Joker
geez road hog um even though he's kind
of not really a pure tank there's really
only one what about you you don't play
as much overwatch as you do titanfall
played you know I'm sure you yeah that's
fair Rockets justice rains from above
kind of makes sense yeah always
intentional you just didn't know it
Jaina Walker it's fine if you just
started titanfall and you're yeah
because you know everyone's got to start
from somewhere it's about the dedication
you put into the game and if you want to
get better
obviously great single player campaign
you don't have to be necessarily great
to get through that obviously and I
think you could easily play this
frontier defense that's you know
obviously start uneasy kind of feel your
way through that and here you go Nick we
got that hot we got that hot Oh your
eyes the rise map here so I didn't get
that first map that's fine we'll have
this one Nick this is this is if Nick is
watching
this is probably gonna be a good one
Swan when if we have time we can do
scorch Rob does also like to play sports
so I already have my Titan
oh I'm joining that's fine oh you're in
the final wave sorry Nick this money as
good as we thought it would be but maybe
we'll try it again
it just kind of sucks Cooper what we're
trying oh yeah it was like okay we'll
play monarch because you know he'll
level up and he'll be beast it's also
lame I'm starting the first or started
the final wave with absolutely
absolutely no money so sick it's fine
but I don't know the things you buy
actually aren't that great like they're
okay
mhm and I would say you would probably
want to wait until you get like the
shield booth shields are really good
probably the one thing you'd want I
think for sure it seems like at least
one of you guys having a century turret
seems pretty key you know just to kind
of get rid of some of that pesky stuff
that you guys might not like necessarily
kill all time ticks or something or like
any of that just like stuff god rad Z
yes you do need to of cause if you ready
almost yeah right okay did you do need
to update it is out it's not just
working for you like I said just restart
your console or prefer platform and okay
mr. joke gamer says when I asked about
executions I forgot to say that I like
the lightning punches a North Star prime
my fourth I'm saying this got to be
sorry
trying to get through as much of chat as
I can obviously doing great a lot of
questions but we appreciate it and I'll
eventually get to it so never fear we
are here god rats you're gonna have to
update to play the mode so if you
haven't updated yet that's probably why
you haven't been able to my god while I
was growing in this up and you're
getting oh hello
that's a great execution by the way
still battery hmm level up baby what's
yours is mine oh man I haven't played
this one in a while North Star sorry
monarch is really fun there's so much
going on you're trying to that's why I
think it's a cool time to have like yeah
it's like mixing it up you know changing
game it basically changes like your
gameplay style obviously blood Overlord
are the new camels where all the guns I
think you're asking yeah that you there
are new war paints for the guns as well
as the Titans those are the games you
can buy them as bundles I'm gonna
believe it it's looking like you have
about a month or so to get that purchase
beside yeah which ones you want 49 $4.99
each or
yeah 24 9s 25 bucks for all that's just
for weapon skins if you wanted a ps4
legend
again just to reiterate the I think so
far favorite DLC might be this one for
Rob but like I said Rob basically like
any new DLC that comes out its truth
that's kind of the answer I got be for
me like I said I really enjoy PvE so
like having a horde mode like this would
be a lot of fun I'm sure the guys in the
pit at some point today or like over the
next couple days
you know like Aaron Sampson like you
steal a battery off an execution - not
so fast oh yeah you can
yeah well that's an ability I think I
don't know if I have it on but you can
get you can prevent a doomed hw1 6:03
we're currently playing on normal
because you have to get the rink by
Vegas ranked 5 on it on any Titan - then
unlock the next mode which makes sense
because you probably need the beefiness
of that Titan C then really deal with
that mode cuz normal by the 4th and 5th
wave get pretty intense
you know last round we kind of got to 40
38 to 40 percent on the the harvester so
Krista see the merits I believed you
carry over from what we can tell so in a
way it does contribute to your overall
multi I think right that's kind of what
we agreed on yeah
what's up Kim's up at the clips Oh your
full name is kim andre Hobden hello
welcome to our titanfall 2 new dlc yeah
I keep forgetting than your operation
frontier shield I keep remember your
operation you want to call an operation
shield but it's frontier she'll run yeah
and then this mode is called frontier
defense oh my god that's a lot of times
it's frontier defense co-op for player
mode for free downloadable today it
sounds like at least for sure we know
ps4 Xbox one haven't heard anyone in the
chat just typically mentioned PC but
yeah cool I got my second abilities so
yeah
this is I think monarchs pretty good for
the stuff thank you
this is the final wave I'm already like
able to get my third Bob Jones telling
me just abbreviated ofs yeah everyone
knows oh we lost a pilot he's gonna not
be available for however long it takes
him to fly in look at a little God role
you want to execute the plan yeah I do
thank you but the thing is I'm afraid to
execute anyone because of my shield is
so freaking low right now but regardless
this guy lo sneak up from behind
I'm gonna beat you up Paula it's gonna
take your batteries oh [ __ ] now which is
now the shield is gone we got we mostly
good huh okay you got your oh that would
have been nice to being able to to get
that guy Chris Thomas thank you YouTube
chat saying PC is up and running
yep ever so we're pretty much up across
the board on all fronts yeah we got 26
enemies we got to deal with that's kind
of a lot and you guys are all starting
to burn it's not good
hey babe we need us okay
I don't know I'm cutting it yeah you're
close here but it's okay another one
that's all cool I got my my big one this
is good oh this is gonna be a real real
hairy here we joined into this match
late unfortunately oh I guess one of
their guys left one of the pilots left
the game so the street type to like
you've never been able to do this which
is like shoot Call of Duty stuff right
here yeah isn't it a c-130 coming in
coming in boys apparat cheese same
premium past bf 1 or 10 fall to the
actual pool game with two pens where yes
I'm sure it's like half bucks probably a
lot feel free I can't even get a
single-player campaign like for that
price I cannot recommend that enough oh
yeah bias I am biased but 30 bucks is
pretty good especially with all this new
content
yes Kevin Lauritzen Lauritzen each each
have rob has played since lunch
he has played some fun
he pretty much plays on and off you know
for fun because he loves the game and
then he definitely goes a little harder
each DLC as most people as it would be
expected right for most people like
because new modes and you new things are
coming out so you know yes it's this
will deftly keep me going like I have
some my close friends I finally got them
convinced to get a ps4 and this came as
a year ago but now we always play so
this is like perfect time Sparta
Spartans a me saying I got titanfall 2
for 20 bucks Haley yes best Best Buy
best pay that's by steal good steal yeah
Felix are all so harkening if you don't
have this game do yourself a favor and
buy now look at that that's so cool
yeah that's pretty cool
well he was Frank Vasquez he was
comparing the the be f1 season pass
versus the full game of titanfall 2 so
in that case I would probably at the
same time we also recommend the actual
titanfall to pool game I'm not gonna get
that nope I got away from that thing
that's the problem is like executions
here if you notice all these guys have
nuclear objection sir Halo fan UNSC
Spartan shoes telling me the repair
schertz they can't be repaired so
considerations there oh how about this
guy how about this guy see that's a
problem that's like they thought of it I
mean like you're you guys are just
holding the fort strong they're not even
like so that would be the monarch
counter essentially right yeah oh yeah
for sure
is you're rushing in trying to get that
execution and then that battery and then
that happens he what's interesting here
is like like this map is pretty easy for
this mode because there's just three
lanes yeah like the other one was a
little more complicated
there were like many ways to approach
the harvester Kevin I don't play as much
as Rob I enjoy watching it I really
should play a little bit more but it's
just hard when there's so many shooters
I'm I'm more of enough like overwatch
kind of guy personally
but that is the beauty of having all
these cool games coming out you know
like I really want to try and give
splatoon ago expose him to ago you know
like a lot of the people in the office
are having a blast with that it's
definitely a different kind of shooter
that you know multiplayer wise doesn't
just emphasize you know killing each
other you know it's about turf battles
and like you can help your team in so
many other ways so like just the beauty
of the age we live in right now Daigo
fan 83 this is free dlc the only thing
that like you can actually spend money
on are the war paints for the guns in
this and the titan wow hey I came in
late Dream Team vlogs I feel bad for you
he says bruh today went to download the
titanfall DLC but my goal trying to find
one of those hot gold deals sometimes
they're like get like someone's saying
that you had the wrong anti-titan weapon
for this mode you feel that's the case
really yeah I guess I could see that
there's more like grunts soul anymore
that olicity vault the mag launcher Oh
what are you kidding this we said oh
let's hope for a map here margarita I
don't know we'll see
what do we want here do that mode again
I think yeah let's do that mode again
cuz I was like kind of like a I kind of
want to see the monarch more than water
like I want to see what that looks like
if you can kind of like make it to the
okay you know alright it seems like such
a PvE style type to Titan it's like you
know it works probably well in PvP too
but it seems to really lend itself so
that like this concept like just
thinking about it and hearing you talk
about it's like that makes sense aidan
go tier assuming I said you might be got
her actually oh he got hurt he says use
the Thunderbolt suitor bolt so one of
the reasons why I'm not using the
thunderbolt is because I want to level
up and Thunderbolt doesn't have a new
skin now someone else saying is Archer
is best I think oh this is
this is good record this oh yeah I'm
recording good I am recording for the
good guy Oh what is up dawg and I should
mute this yeah probably
sorry we don't know what they're gonna
say he probably heard outro normal but
it never sounded like a nice man yeah
you did and that that's also the beauty
you never know you might run into some
co-op guys that maybe you friend up with
future so that you kind of get through
these modes level up your your aigis
ranks faster you know I'm changing my
mind I won't go back to this Kevin bring
up another good point you know he's
currently installing it loving the free
updates doesn't feel like respawn gets
enough credit I think it's kind of the
new model though in a way it's like okay
cool you know what we're gonna kind of
try to give you as much free content as
we can and then we're also gonna just
give you cosmetics and if you want to
buy those cosmetics great but those
cosmetics ultimately help them make the
next piece of content right they have
Tom but you also don't have to buy them
all so they look really cool nice one
now that'd be kind of cool though I keep
making these overwatch references but it
would be kind of cool if they had do
that because like you can't buy them
with like in-game currency right like
not these they should kind of do that
that overwatch thing where it's like
really expensive to get that skin but if
you really want to work for it
I agree because like yeah I agree like I
spent like three thousand gold which is
a lot in overwatch you know what I mean
but you really got that skin you wanted
you know so it was worth it right so
like it'd be nice if maybe they
incorporated something like that in the
future but you know at the same time you
keep the plane Oh get out of there oh
you who can complain when you're getting
actually getting free DLC and free
content like yeah I think that we more
important right larceny yeah we are
fortunate and and we can't just be like
greedy I want to say greedy bastards and
be like oh yeah like you know like they
should give this to us it's like how
businesses work
you know I think oh you know you think
about like the last five years I think
it's kind of nice that I think most
games have real our franchises even have
a kind of realized that locking maps out
of the picture isn't healthy for like a
community like that's that's nice that
we've kind of steered away from that
because yeah there's nothing more
frustrating than like oh I don't have
the update so when we when we do a you
know like a playlist and I get tossed
out that's not good I'm like you're
separating Titan Bob we're boys reading
for at least another half an hour maybe
a little bit more we stream every day at
11:00 a.m. guys for about 60 to 90
minutes usually closer to 90 minutes
Monday we are we have Jake and Mike
they're doing some pub G they're really
getting into those chicken dinners so
check it out Monday's for pub G streams
they might not always do coke G but
right now that's kind of the thing for
them Tuesdays you're usually seeing me
on hosting you know new DLC or new games
that are coming out Wednesdays we have
our weekly kind of talk show where we
talk about you know big news big updates
you know big reviews it's called the
lobby of course that's also at 11:00
a.m. Thursday we have Rob and Peter
right now they're they're doing Triforce
they're back at it again doing some
master mode in Zelda yeah they also do
some other fun things they were doing
Dino DNA for a while so for now they're
probably gonna do a lot of oh yeah see
ya gotta try forth but this Thursday
just so you guys know it will not be
Triforce we're actually gonna do a short
night livestream we're gonna be joined
by the devs we're gonna get to see some
cool kind of like a little bit later
you know someone's like the later heroes
and whatnot and just like how to build
cool forts and whatnot
and then Friday we will we have Joey and
John Luke they're starting to do a thing
where we've cleaned up our game library
so they might be playing some older
games we're gonna see if we can get some
of these ps1 games to work in our stream
room here and if they do they might be
going through some disney ps1 games this
week that's the hope we'll find out not
confirmed but it's definitely gonna be
Joey and John Luke so catch them on
Fridays at 11:00 a.m.
Daigo fan 83 asking what would be
streaming Abigail for SF 5 probably not
but maybe if there's not too much going
on next week maybe we'll do an SF 5
Abigail stream one of our fighting game
aficionados in the in the office Richard
Lee loves playing new Street Fighter 5
characters getting good with them
Abigail might be a fun fun one to play
against in terms of competitive mode but
we really want appreciate you guys
tuning in and if you guys want to check
out those streams you know obviously
give us a fall and the like again as I
mentioned streaming I'd let every day at
11 a.m. sometimes we'll have maybe an
extra stream but definitely every day at
11 a.m. yeah and way to go on that long
list schedule drops yeah I'll try to
give will try to once we nail down the
schedule and kind of like what we're
doing we'll definitely have that out so
you guys can see that visually as well
to help you guys know that where we're
going what we're kind of going through
so really appreciate you guys hanging
out with us really appreciate and have
fun chatting with you guys and all the
questions
what's wrong why I wanna get selected
God dang it
were you just like changing without
knowing I don't I get I must have yeah
and the unfortunate thing here is that
once he's locked like the Titans are
locked in but you can change your your
pilot specs right between rounds just
you can't change your title
yeah that's fine we'll roll with the
punches Islands good though I'll
probably save for this thing
go of HD saying lovin the stream guys
love and he also loved he or she also
loved sign fall to you again do you
appreciate you being here love that you
guys are here with us guys and gals yeah
it appears to be out on all platforms
guys so if you're looking to play it you
know wouldn't mind if you guys left the
stream on and play it at the same time
but obviously you know understandable if
you guys just went and played it you
know enjoy yourselves
obviously Spartan gaming mentioning that
since he got such a good deal on the
titanfall to actual game that he's gone
ahead and spend some of some leftover
money on some skins and prime Titans
that seems pretty fair to me yeah cuz
like I mean my logic and rationale would
be like okay cool I spent you know
twenty dollars on games I really want
this skin cuz I really played this
character a lot you know yeah yes right
then you're ultimately like okay spent
like another 15 dollars or whatever it
was spent 35 for a game that you're
gonna spend a lot of time playing
obviously
you know money spent is kind of like how
much time you're gonna spend with the
game you know to each their own cuz you
know some people have more money than
others some you know some people value
things differently but you know the
options there right and I always feel
like if I play a game a lot that like
those things are valuable and worth it
to me so I think one of the best
examples of like the like well it's a
free to play game what has really good
like just like cosmetics and things like
that is a path of Exile oh yeah they've
been around for like so long and they've
never charged a dime
you know they've done it all through
like cosmetics and their communities
really showing I think when you build
that community like that's how you you
thrive
yeah you will not shoot me that's cool
to hear I guess it's nice to hear and
that actually works out
lotta love for titanfall there Rob
you're not the only one not the only
bone 22 because like you probably can't
see it but i-i've been trying to fill up
this like will kind of Tetris shelf
behind me that you can kind of see with
some cool like you know gaming related
toys and one I you can't see it but at
the very top is actually a titanfall to
funkopop I bought it because Rob loves
titanfall to so much that I figured into
it was really doing a pretty reasonable
thing to have on the shelf is some
overwatch stuff back there to fallout we
got koku you know oh do not need to do
it but I did it anyway right reminds me
so much of like Ironman like the hell
yeah man like Marvel games where he
would like do the unibeam out of his
chest
yeah can't wait to play dragon fall
fighters think that that beta signups on
the 26 we're gonna get like nine
characters beta at the end of the summer
I will definitely be playing back I
should get this one 10 Bob can't wait to
get home to play this o frontier defense
mode glad you're tuning in thanks see
you get home
Kevin asked you do you think we'll see a
time fall to be robbed or do they screw
over respawn with the release or did
they screw over respawn with the release
window well I think we'll definitely see
timeful three but I don't think any time
soon because I believe they're working
on one of the new Star Wars games
respond so maybe it'll take a little
break but I personally um I don't know I
like this game so much that I don't
personally need pen ball three right now
I would not want it next year right I
have maybe I don't know and like they
would cuz like this is one of those
harder games were like one of those
games that's harder to kind of like how
do we change it but keep the core intact
right like totally where do we find ways
to keep evolving it and they're kind of
doing that through the DLC content in a
way so right there's that right oh
you're actually right like they're
they're keeping me engaged and if they
were to do a third game like you'd want
it to be a step up a bigger step up than
just these DLC updates right like like
you know what if titanfall 3 just
started next year and it was just this
co-op mode added to it yeah be that
would be underwhelming right like you
gotta come time to like figure out what
are we go from here
Jared biruta the Funko pop titanfall 2
that we have is the Jake one there's
like multiple though that we could have
picked from I want a spot to I was like
they kind of look too similar oh yeah so
it's just like almost like a color
change and also because you really can't
see Adam Joyce is there a new universal
camel pack yes there's Neil Warpaint's
that you can purchase weapons and Titans
you can either buy them as a bundle or
individually for $4.99 each $24.99
bundle believe it lasts until August 20
they have about a month get those
yeah that's a good point Sparta gave me
saying that at least for now he would
rather see like a really big deal see
that you guys would potentially pay for
instead of a tight ball three like a
nice meaty DLC downloadable yeah could
be a way to like yeah the next thing
they could do is like single-player I
guess like more single-player content
yeah I see you
my he definitely played story mode I
played like 1 or 2 missions I played a
really cool one there are a couple very
memorable oh good night good here's your
bottle of milk to go to sleep with
except it's a big laser the old face
Chris Beaumont in the chat get out yeah
says one of his a favorite - oh sorry
for yelling
it's alright like I was stuck he gave he
had me stuck
I'm a very weakly oh sorry Adam he said
like Angel City camo pack I don't know
about that I don't think so Daniel
stated what about it he said is there
like a camel pack like the Angel City
camel pack they they're doing something
different with our adding like just
groups of like more more or less
Universal like packs so you get like
like this summer I look like there's
like a group or knows art 3 or never so
every every Titan you can't buy a nose
art and have it work for every time but
you have to buy that nose art photo you
know explaining with my hand off the
controller yeah I'm like man you have
time to Steve Jobs while you're in the
heat of the battle with a Titan right in
front of you no problem
oh this is a problem no you guys no you
this is over this is definitely a wrap
okay
Oh JK Rob's on the scene except there's
like 10 Titan shooting at your it
doesn't really seem to matter does it
there are T Erik see all these signs you
don't want this no yeah definitely not
this is what will happen
terminators and the a eyes of the world
take over right
Oh God yeah that was good you got a
Titan oh I'll drop in the wrong way you
survive the problem then walk out
I shouldn't even done this waste time
for the stream you good see Oh God now
what we need is for the rest of your
team to buy like amp like the shield
boosts and then every time it gets
really low on shield you guys just have
to uh you know pop the shield get your
anvil one thing this is a great map yes
another 900 bucks for that no problem
should I not spend anything I want a
battery okay I think you should just
save for the shield I should have I
really should have but I don't think
we're gonna we're gonna make it Kyra
asking do you think they might bring in
some of the older Titans like Atlas or
over all right not right they're gonna
do other one oh right you're looking
firm those you're kind of looking at
those Titans over is the chassis right
so like this is what were they from us
game over atlas
so that's atlas would be the medium
built no no that would be the one over
Atlas and I'll think of it
Strider Strider Strider is like you know
there are six Titans seven those those
Titans from the first game have this
right they do there's just like they've
been kind of thinned out and then and
then repurposed into different class
yeah and we know we're getting two more
right like or like worse right like we
know that we're game so right so we'd be
getting the like an ogre chassis or new
Titan and then a Strider last stream I
pull it up those those
[ __ ] I think I actually still have
someone but I'm not gonna pull them up
right now
hello Korean Tom fine Bob saying this
was his favorite man yeah this man was
really cool and oh one also informing
and oh one gaming also informing us that
Scorch am Legion are the overclass
Titans if for what that's worth
how are ya nerf to smg's Rob nerve to
SMG smg's say it ain't so I'll double
check that for you pilot balance in
general ARS and SSDs require you to be
to aim the aiming closer to your target
before any 80s assist takes effect and
SMGs medium and long range significantly
reduced one of the positive changes we
saw at high at ttk playlists was the
increase of weapon diversity it's our
hope that between the aim-assist nerf
and this SMG nerf will see weapons
diversity diversity increased traffic
quality plat maps Eric this was a very
good wow you're fine your shields
totally fine for now
what's the thing what's okay this guy
shooting drones or that was the
centrifuge on which is fine you just
have sixty enemies that's that's no big
deal right
sure what's up my business hello and
from YouTube cat welcome welcome
we're doing alright as long as like one
of us like I'm back here just kind of
picking off the stragglers like all
these guys on our team are kind of yeah
we're kind of sitting now he's like wage
if I see a slushee miss gaming saying I
wish that my game would finish updating
the only thing offer advice rather not
the advice advice is that um if your arm
like a ps4 you could try going into rest
mode or five download faster other than
that I got nothing for you that's funny
I thought I wish this would hurry the F
oh hey I mean you're staying at a bar I
remember like earlier today you gave me
the thumbs up like it's a man I'm like
cool as it dunt down right cool it's out
let's see if it actually downloads a
maniac Brainiac great name they did add
this map it is from San : its rise no
your this this is rise watch this shape
I'm watching Oh tiny tiny little up
that's cool that's cool
oh drones are infesting your harvester
where's my team not around
definitely not oh dude I'll protect it
come at me
oh my god all Easter your self-destruct
took out something planners
yeah I'd say hair that's entry
especially where that right there oh
it's just chilling okay
well I was pretty smart dropping the
shield in front of the harvester digging
that guy another guy just got a you put
a shield in front of the harvester Oh as
I on yeah that's the call yeah it's cool
to see bees like Titans like applied to
more defensive roles with their
abilities and such yeah you're just on
your own patrol now actually I kind of
forgot these were the single air hot
cloak action look I cannot see him he's
so cloaked Harvester shield is back up
you were gonna be fine I think your team
hopefully has learned that they
shouldn't go too far oh no it's fine the
wave is complete we're good we're good
all right cool so I got it does speed up
downloads from what I know only does
yeah it totally does save your energy
for rear vortex shield Oh 18 withdrawal
god rad saying dude my update says it'll
be done in two hours go into rest mode
is all I can say P shizzle that's
correct horde mode and titanfall with a
nice emote of like like a person
recommend we do this sir Halo fan says
you have to be directly behind the turd
and you should show an option to repair
it because it look like that that shirt
was down right yeah because it was
scrunched up so maybe next time we can
check that out what explain to me where
the the behind area is well the other
one when it was down was stationary so
maybe like directly I don't know we'll
see what's up Adam Lyra hello welcome
welcome welcome to chat where's my baby
baby
this is gonna be real this is gonna be
real hot finish here photo finish 15
percent
yeah can we do it that's the real
question Eric I'm playing us Northstar
now any advice I have to ask Rob he's
the North Star expert advice always be
running away that's hey let me finish
you you cannot you cannot be in the
front lines as North Star you are a
sniper a glass cannon you are in the
background sniping picking off always
Chargers shots to the max to get that
that's full damage dealt with each shot
when you aim down sights you'll see kind
of like a hologram red area of where you
playing man you're doing that one-handed
thing and it's make you want to get
critical hits as I'm seeing so you want
to shoot Titans in the face in order to
best utilize North Stars and I guess
just as a side note to kind of what Rob
was saying you kind of want to like hug
the buildings where I pop out when
you're gonna do those shots and try not
to take any damn you know
the other way yeah the other thing I
would say is against pilots it's a
little tricky because you have you know
such a slow fire rate is there's an
ability called threat optics which lets
when you aim down sights all pilots are
lit up what are you pointing out air
it's nothing I was gonna point at your
terp I thought it was down but it looks
over oh you want someone to shoo a
parent yeah but don't worry about that
for now you got drones to deal with
right now yeah
parents squat I'm like those gnats that
they are gnats drone gnats come here
alright boys we need it we need it you
really need to buckle up
we need to buckle up here doing okay
Adam Lyra is this Nouveau fun yes Rob's
having a blast we've been kind of doing
the thing that you shouldn't be doing
which is shuffling our Titans because
one your tight rank is what kind of
let's we progress to the next difficulty
mode of this new frontier right so you
want to stick with one tie and if you
want to level up a Titan per se like
we've so far we've tried out three I did
not mean to pick this one I should
though freaking sorry Khyber it might be
hard to hack as like there's so many
drones to hack that I don't know how
viable that would be but yeah it's
definitely worth a try
Amba one also just giving us another tip
on Northstar that you know you don't
necessarily need to charge your shot
fully to get a kill on a pilot it's true
Oh exactly yeah the pilots you don't
even bother charging the other thing
about Northstars I would say I know
what's cool about sides is you can
always diversify so it's like you know
if you want to focus on a North Star is
also North Stars core ability where you
do the justice strains from above it's
super risky or die really fast because
you're also a chair you're up in the air
everyone sees you you're you're already
like dealing with low health compared to
other ties and so like you can get
picked out of sky however if you really
want to invest into it what do you doing
turn around
oh your views on auto auto yeah Adam get
on Pato
oh that's pretty good you spun out the
back off off the explosion you have the
other thing about North Stars yes if you
wanted to invest into that poor ability
you can do like the ability Viper Jets
where you float around faster when
you're hovering which is actually pretty
fun so you can like like circle guys
they won't have enough time to aim at
you you can kind of just get the high
mobility when you're engaging your core
ability so it's like I've done it before
it's like damn actually this core
abilities work very well now yeah Alex
what's up man sorry that your updates
gonna take 110 minutes there's a lot of
people telling me that they've got that
like 90 plus minute download as I
mentioned all I could say is your ps4
try putting it in rest mode that does
help and you know otherwise hang out
with us as we check this mode on we'll
answer as we can please Abby lays it
down the lane this is pretty good for
this this map in particular it seems
like that they did you clump up in these
way yeah you know what I mean like yeah
it's a good map for this yeah la
chapelle we didn't mean to play monarch
for some reason it's like defaulted to
eye on some Island I okay I'll take the
blame Ivan
realizing battery oh this became a
limited time only
Sherman gee that's tough to say sure
more sorry if I butchered your name it's
a free DLC that you can get right now
frontier operation frontier shield OFS
you can get it now and yes a new co-op
PvE board mode you do five waves there
are five difficulties total for that you
can see that there's easy normal is it
there's something hard and then master I
think of which masts are hard you got to
get to rank five agus on one Titan or
any tighten and then maybe masters like
ten I'm not sure I didn't we didn't
check the what we can check after and
this is out now agent 2800 it we've
confirmed that it's on all platforms via
the chat PC Xbox as well as ps4 this is
currently normal mode Nick men breed and
because we haven't gotten a agus rank
five yet so it looked like after winning
one match with the Northside we got the
two not sure how fast the leveling is
but it'd be nice it feels like
bring her win but what I see oh yeah no
get away from him oh that was taxing
that was now worth not worth it at all
any kind of shield did the rest of the
stuff behind it which is unfortunate
right that's right I think this is the
final eat dude what happened to in wave
three that like where you guys almost
just absolutely blew it and then now
like wave fives like alright guys it's
gotta get serious you can totally tell
we've just been managing these lanes
uh-huh and they're kind of trading off
back and forth to help man they're kind
of sneaking up here good so you have two
down pilots right now so get out damn it
we may or may not be okay
- your guys just flew in so it might be
okay this is really when having that
that clutch shield man this range is
pretty shitty maybe that's pretty good
you guys are talking about but yeah one
of the things you can buy in the armory
is the ability to kind of bring your
harvesters shield back up to 100% right
like all each one of you got your guys
had one yeah like that's like three
lives almost or that could be the key to
like you know the harder modes is making
sure that you have those so that you
know when you are getting overwhelmed
you can instantly kind of like get your
shield back up to really buy time
these turrets are doing work though yeah
they are like a mine still up like
that's pretty part of it as well yeah
but like you said you guys have been
managing the lanes like a lot better so
you guys haven't been overwhelmed by
some more stuff in line and there hasn't
been any other grunts there's just been
these that like there hasn't been any
writers Reapers can like like a lot more
of those like like smaller as I had
mentioned pesky things right which can
take your time right like opposed to
just focusing on just heightens just
maybe where we like loss of us Adam
Lehrer Rob's favorite favorite pilot
class despite the cloaking one yeah
God rads asking what's the best tiny
used in frontier defense so far marnark
seems pretty good I would say monarch
iins been pretty good I don't know I
think you we want to have a some
diversity I think monarch we're we're
theory crafting as like you know because
we're going through so many levels and
the ability to get so many executions
that's how you level up monarch so so
fast that like he could be that Titan
could be kind of like one of the ones
that could really work out and in this
mode but yeah man you really are like
that's what we should just identify you
as homeland security
hey man towards the end there no one
else was uh yeah how long did that take
you want to try it one more yeah I think
so all right let's get monarch let's
let's make sure you get monarch okay
uh-huh and then that's how we're gonna
wrap with the stream
hopefully our theory craft things right
and monarch is potentially one of the
better Titans to use I could see I could
also see like Oh
scorch or Legion being really great like
Legion just minigun action adds what's
not fast actually yeah so you almost you
ring oh no you ranked it to okay yeah
turrets that wasn't one go three so he
wants it so it does it does seem like oh
you want it now can you give me another
card Nick because I was gonna record
another match we're just handing them
off some gameplay here oh this skin I
got it hey Rob Lesha Pelle Alex asking
Archer or charge rifle there's been some
debates here you like the archer cuz you
want um lit right yeah and it's got it's
the one with the new skin I actually
understand maybe what they were saying
is when I'm coming in on that drop ship
which is fairly quick when I die did you
pick monarch or you on scores right now
we might happen again
yeah sorry I just really have to like
nail this home before we yeah right
potentially get the rock right so you
can go to this venue here and then kind
of guarantee you're gonna pick in there
but they were saying the thunderbolt i
believe is the other
duder bolt you can try it when I get in
the match yeah because the pilot loadout
you can't change yeah with the
Thunderbolt you can actually fire from
the dropship cuz it's so far every time
I've come in when I've died with the
archer I wasn't able to lock on anything
until you got closer right until I
literally got out of the dropship so you
know that's some time where you're not
really doing anything for your team but
I'll put out it could be pretty tough
with the spectrum mentioning says this
PC has low harddrive space only has a
256 gigabyte SSD and only eight gigs of
RAM what kind of shooter game can you
play counter-strike the old 11.6 baby
that's what I would go it well there's a
lot you probably left for dead with that
there's a lot of older older games that
you could get into that don't need as
much uh much of X this should be tricky
homestead yeah cuz a lot of wider area
right
yeah very much uh North Star could be
pretty good here mmm my business same
monarch is if you want to be a support
hero basically iron is a versatile
region
bang bang bang oh stop shooting tone is
rocket man mm scorches area to now more
Saurez sniped get Snipes alright I like
those classifications
you know I'm gonna do mag launcher I
think that's what better really get a
mag it up yeah cuz it's good against
I've been tree that like spread Oh put
that nice skin on did you put that you
can offer your yeah this one sick so I
don't use this gun people love yeah I
think this is the best looking skin to
behind but stay there last lastima is
that character armory Chula Vista
something something that's pretty sweet
this right here battlefield one has
skins like this but kind of like gold
lining I like the detail though it's got
that uh looks really good gonna make
that overwatch reference against that
mariachi Reaper now I got a level the
sting up so I can put a decent scope on
it do it Purple Haze the DLC is out it
is playable on Xbox one ps4 as well as
PC Alicia more we are currently playing
on ps4 good night all of you grunts
we really do need someone that's kind of
babysitting it a little bit because like
you know your seems come in immediately
there's a lot to your right to you right
now I love this gun I don't know this
gun that well though oh you'll get to
know it I don't know I was just giving
me some thoughts of a cow what gun is
that asked Kevin so this is one of the
new ones
oh damn he launches the drones or no
ticks this is the G to Saul rifle chichi
or well keeps - G - G - Ryan's Mia the
FAL nice little single shotgun that
people like this gun I know that like it
sounds awesome I like it I'm liking her
I like the magazine change - I think I
just like the skin this is the other
this is the new skin so this would be
five bucks by itself or 25 for the whole
collection of this collection probably
like seven guns get new skins like this
that will increase your XP I'm just
interesting is I don't if you or know
this is that titanfall you don't ever
run out of your primary weapon ammo like
I don't know how many games that do that
oh it's like overwatch is that right
yeah you don't have a good ammo pool in
the game right apologies to see some of
the YouTube chatters I appreciate you
guys I'm asking if you can join Rob
but this prior our last map no apologies
maybe we'll think about that next time
yeah well we were kind of worried that
we weren't even sure if we would be able
to get into the the mode in time for you
guys at 11:00 here apparently the g2 got
nerfed though reduced to fire rate right
I see that yeah Wow
gun guy saying his Ronin is agus ranked
13 nice damn that's pretty high already
woah that's it that's all you're using
right yeah you do four or five matches
maybe you can get that I'm not sure
we're gonna is regionally but I will say
that I believe Europe and Australia got
it all my flowers before the US did so
they might have been playing for a while
now remember like no I just got an hour
ago
Adam Lehrer uh Borderlands III enjoy the
game in the concept but something about
the the style or something it makes me
get motion sickness and for this game
no bore lamb could be a specific lasting
about Borderlands I would have loved to
have played that game but I couldn't
play for more than fifteen to thirty
minutes at a time without getting sick
and I don't know if there was anything
like mode that I could have changed to
make that better like doom I was getting
really sick from playing the new doom
that is but I turned off like
anti-aliasing or something or like some
type of motion blur and anything and
then I was able to play that game and I
loved that game that game is great if
you guys haven't played doom
like a single-player doom is real good
if it's cheap I would say you should
definitely play that it's really good
yeah I love doom and that's funny you
say that cause like I could totally
understand cuz that game is like so high
paced like even like some people say
like watching games yeah someone else
play is a big deal and I think I can
kind of see that I can watch this
there's some some FPS games that I've
been on with some other people that I'm
like whoa that's making me a little sick
we're just familiar right like this is
very like Cod right like it's been
around this this style of FPS Jared
scorch me in here and proud my dudes
yeah awkward of course my second
favorite oh here we go
monarch you know I think maybe part of
it is to I don't know if this if you
have messed with it but fov like I have
you cranked up to the max I feel that -
yeah ah guy got better ingredients
better pizza Papa scorch Papa scorched
everyone calls it Papa's courts
man there's gorgeous so good is it good
keep him coming guys I will read them
all right so we're putting the theory
crafting the to the test here yeah we
want our X we're trying to see if our
recommendation to you guys is true or
not we're also doing the I guess it
cleared t-bag Titan Dan spree waves here
there's your scorch we've got a couple
scores here hello what's up
what's worse new collegian or reaper
nucleation or reaper i think so far
nucleons have been the worst yeah
they've like especially now right look
we're trying to get executions in order
to level up monarch here so about to see
three pretty easy for the most part like
as long as they have those torso yeah
they're just annoying they can like give
you a bad time oh what the hell are my
business saying that's what you should
use flatline if you have
I got killed by a reaper fall earlier
says good guy that's my debt so that
happened to us I think it fell on us
yeah like are you doing your Steve Jobs
no I was advancing and like it kind of
indicated that he was dropping and he
took like half my shield earlier you
said tix did you mean spicy boys how are
your calm that's what the chats called
them they said takes our spicy boys that
makes sense
sure we'll go with that will call them
spicy boys from now on all of another
puff escorts domain in the chat and the
Papa scorches are coming out yeah you're
right so shady I was not a huge fan of
zoom multiplayer I didn't think that was
as good as the single-player I just
really enjoyed the single-player yeah
and I think there's some replayability
there with that that are really like
that one life mode man like for those of
those Papa Scorch fans in there if you
saw the Vegas rank like the max one and
like the second to last one you get to
fire three incendiary shots at once
before reloading like that's such a big
move is it's like such a chore to reload
with sports easily like the longest fire
rate and it's a single shot so like
having three at the ready is just
bonkers I'm just that one guy don't kill
Papas or don't kill scorch he's our papa
Papa scorches life Papa scorches love ya
- Adam yeah we I've only played a little
bit of horizon zero dawn I know Rob's
played a bunch I know a lot of people
and I have to finish it and I have
enjoyed it though
Jared Baretta hopefully I said your last
name right sorry if I did love the
stream my dudes
keep it up we're gonna try but vjp
asking how do you feel about tone
tighten tone tighten I don't really know
him that well tone and Ronin and like my
least played Titans like I own a lot for
me it goes like North Stars torch I on
heavy mark is up a little higher yeah
Chris they say okay just got here not
yet seen any tf2 gameplay contains well
Titans could kind of jump up depending
on how you look at it I guess like
North's Ark explodes hello I can - left
and right and backwards it's and it's
definitely faster than just walking
sideways
mama I on his life while my eye on his
love mama mama I on now now we got the
better pizza better ingredients are we
starting to fall to pieces stream here I
don't know Papa's quartz sounds better
better sounds better with pizza if you
could find another way to phrase ions oh
yeah someone brought out a good point I
think that's gonna guy sorry I didn't
mention this earlier coming from the
YouTube chat saying when double X
becomes one munch one match or frontier
defense can give you 20 each time that's
two levels of match it's pretty good
because you get ten merits I think her
finished frontier defense apparently
that sucks Jody 343 happened they hadn't
gone on their ps4 for months and they
just got on but all their data for
titanfall 2 it's gone that sucks wait
what oh man all their Titans are locked
I don't know are you sure you didn't
regen maybe that's thanks Adam Randall
subscribe we appreciate it yeah that's
just a nice reminder for everyone else
in chat I'm Eric that's Rob titanfall -
seal aficionado here in the GameSpot
offices we're in YouTube twitch and
GameSpot if you haven't already liked
and followed and subscribed you know
please do that we go live every day at
11 and also it's just a good way to get
notified for any of our cool VOD content
as well not only just our live content
so we appreciate you guys hanging out
all that fun stuff yeah Monica's really
fun to use have you executed anyone yet
no one had this
there was one Titan last round that goes
too far away best thing is I feel like
it's gonna be hard like there aren't
really any close spaces it might be
harder but I think we have a tie-in
right here Felix I'm not sure when
respawn won't stop kind of giving out
free dlc do you know like they have they
have some plans for a few more of as far
as this year goes I think it's a couple
more but I'm sure it'll keep going for a
while I'm not sure if they'll like and
at the end of the year but I do know
that like sorts this year goes they have
a bunch more planned for release that's
pretty good eye on man Papa sports
schemata Ronin fan Bob said I subscribe
thank you Titan Bob preciate to
subscribe Titan Bob la la Chapelle Alex
baby butterfly monarch love baby
butterfly hunter kiss like I'm still
gonna pop a scourge I still think that's
that's the one to go to so far yeah
don't know Tyler Tyler I don't know why
time fall is so underrated but we're
enjoying it a lot of the chats enjoying
it so that's good gun guy saying game
swap bearing idea appreciate that we do
appreciate that
oh you gotta execute I've got to find a
way get up there
punch them too far alright there's a guy
over here though sue happens make it
happen
I'm just that one guy what guns Italian
so you guys enjoy using I use r97 it's
gorgeous
sometimes north are funny enough rob
primarily uses North Star and yeah
sports and a MIDI monarch really like a
market monarch great especially here
it's more calm because I level up that's
that's the thing about this mode is like
it gets easier
oh yeah gun guy Jen's 78 : the 17 Ronin
main here sagen what Jen are you for my
Titan why'd I I reached level 10 for
North Star other ones I'm not too sure
what about you like pilot Jack it's
seven okay seven point something Dan
Slott to you 5 9 thank you says you guys
are really good at this that's really
Rob playing I'm just reading Chad I'm
really good at reading chat does that
count squats yeah I'm good no just
kidding
why did I get up watch her play dead see
if I can get some or at least you more
use the Legion yeah a legion I feel like
would be really good here oh yeah the
time to get some level ups here
speaking of Legion dammit yeah that's
right Marcus young better ingredients
better pizza Papa Sports is right still
the best one today the mama ion was
alright and butterfly was about to get
it oh no she is it just Legion
well they say on their thing so like oh
so I chose the new yeah I should avoid
that really nice let's go find that
scorch over there there we go
Papa's porches hot fest course no it's
alright we'll get the other Papas torch
so we're no one with Papa scorch his
battery was not lost in video chats
gonna love that how dad oh man that's
real tough Adam we're all-time favorite
game Rob what this is probably one of my
all-time favorite shooters okay nice
save there nice eh I don't know that's a
really tough one where zelda blew me
away this year blood-borne was a big one
for me got me into the got me into the
souls series and that genre destiny i
play a lot of destiny I'm not Shane
saving us
oh damn should I do this if I do this
I'll be barn games why how are you so
good it's really Rob how are you so good
I'm Isis Rob and playing a lot thank you
gun guy cuz they are an idea bang got
fired
oh look at this I'm about to hit my
third core ability on nice I like it
cha you know what we did we it's like
when we kill a Papa Scorch it's like
we're really killing you know almost
like the - Cory Papa squirts dancing for
y'all everyone go whoop whoop says man
come on
PC that I did woo amazing execution yeah
he was my papa
he was Papa we hug them all we're huntin
we ate his pizza yeah we we got a reaper
here thought you could sneak around the
corner huh alright you could you could
get this guy right got it
upgrade court he doesn't have that who
doesn't have that goal he doesn't have
that we could definitely absorb him you
can absorb him take us so we got a Shang
Tsung um
your sword is behind him oh man see
worry too far away this isn't good why
did he get out you're trying to get back
in oh we had to steal his battery for
our monarch tightening that's part of
yeah you should and you get a shield so
monarch is all about come on I've got a
shield sorry cut you out there you say
what do you think of destiny a new deity
called Daphne - that's not true I think
it's too early to tell oh definitely I
definitely do feel a little bit that I
don't I can see why the destiny to beta
has made people think that it's just
kind of like a glorified destiny but I
feel like there's a lot of new
things coming down the pipeline that we
haven't seen yet that is what made me
more present
cetera when here we are levelling of
Monarch because you think that it's a
pretty good one for this mode yeah
absolutely
howdy how are you feeling about it now
that you're kind of getting to like it
you know I protocol mask but you know
the thing about monarch is like it's
it's probably the most intensive Titan
as far as timing your core abilities I'm
sorry you're just your abilities in
general so like you want to like do that
consistently I've like trading back and
forth and knowing when to rearm your two
other abilities if I don't if you know
like my different moves here is I have
my siphon basically died from honour
you're so weak that it's all about
taking other people's shields and
putting it on to yourself so I'm doing
that and then I'm getting rid of my
missiles and then I'm rearming and then
I could do it all again real quick so
you're like that's the cooldowns that
you're really managing and while all the
while staying away from combat and
getting your other three core upgrades
going so now I'm maxed out so I'm like
I'm like really over P right now yeah
okay right so you can't level of anymore
then not that I know of
okay let's see there's a lot of good
chat going on let's see we got who's
your wife we type mine is ion and
monarch his is North Star and
sport like it monarch as a third a lot
of Papa scorches up in here the MA mark
says Doug guy that's decent pun right
there well now is the time to be a
sports man for sure you've got a lot of
upgrades hot buffs I can read some of
those busts and you didn't know about
them
there were balanced patches like in this
patch of balance with them for titans
and pilots scorch will now have one -
charge within a 10 second cooldown you
got increased firewall with ya scorch
kits wildfire learn to wildfire launcher
now increases the direct hit the average
of the thermite launcher still increases
the amount of fire spread scorched earth
lingering fire lasts longer tempering
tempered plating now makes scorching
Munich crits and his own thermite charge
and he they fixed the bug with a flame
core not igniting in Scenario charge so
a lot of fun stuff
so I have my third and final up core
upgrade is this like awesome lock on in
this little that like you can lock on to
many targets and paint a whole bunch
which would sound good for this mode as
there are a lot of targets as far as
these waves go see Northstar be really
good here to get on that roof
apparently Jarrod says it's not delivery
to journos is good not happy with it
it's lunch time and oh it is real great
good point well this is the last one we
got one more way alright let's do it
is the leveling system different is it
connected to the PvP one some of its
from what we can tell is multiplayer as
well unless I'm wrong Rob say it again
I'm sorry is the leveling system
different or is it connected to the PvP
one I mean there's a there's a slight
leveling difference in that they're just
a guess ranks that's better that
pertains to just this mode run to your
defense
yeah frontier defense the the co-op
weight base mode but like I'm I'm fairly
sure you're leveling up your Titans
regardless it could be wrong well duro
says this seems too easy are you playing
in wimpy mode no this is normal mode I
feel like I created Maps though have
been harder yes smaller Maps maybe like
when they kind of start overwhelming
this one's been pretty open and so like
there you're not clumping together and
attacking you as much I guess maybe it's
they're more spread out I'm not sure for
sure and one of the things I would
recommend if you want to get to the next
difficulty mode which is hard stick to
one Titan because it says you need to
get one Titan to hit level 5 aegis rank
which I don't think we've done yet
because I was too hard until we got
there but no I don't think so I mean
like we wanted to experiment with
different
Titans weren't sure how long it was
gonna take to get to rank five so it's
hard to say but uh yeah there are
caveats caveat rather sorry to getting
to the next modes of difficulty they're
far for total or sorry there's five
technically before that you can select
from insane mode is only see what the
works they just said that insane
difficulty as well that will exist in a
separate tile as a feature the mode I
guess down the road or atom Lehrer
asking do you like Roger they do we mmm
that's a game we're still playing and I
have some plans well excuse me Reaper
calm down yeah
also this mode I haven't seen the mortar
Titans huh we kill them really quick oh
I've been really easy yeah we'll
probably see him this time we're not it
might be just on the last way so that
happened for two ways I felt like on the
other map which was wargames
upgrade core online and even okay you
want to go Achtung well like I just like
I don't even know if there's a need to
realize it well you already use it I
guess let me just get filled back on
yeah
do you know if a titanfall has dedicated
servers are they like quite I don't know
that's a good question from Chris a from
you to town I'm not 100% sure
maybe so nyan cat may know so chat
usually has her back now it's kind of
getting crazy the title everything and
I'm gonna rock there's a lot of nuclear
styled Titans as you all back up
yeah right like oh it's getting hot a
lot of drone over or under that Rob gets
homeland security again what's up city
23 a long time to see you glad to see
you fat all right you finish the
challenge good damn it
are there any achievements Bob Oh
give me your sword
are there any achievements yeah are
there like any trophies associated with
this boat you know that's a good
question I would imagine something with
Vinnie masters and Sandy Bernstein
oh no I did it I did it I did it I did
it yeah
get out
you gotta recognize what you're fighting
dj1 our Poppa scores from a jessic Norse
time whoa I thought that was a little
close yeah no one cares about youto dang
don't cares about what no one cares
about you tone is what I'm just that one
guy wrote a man even a tone needs some
love oh so now you lost all your buffs
huh for my idea that's unfortunate
don't forget later if you need it you
got the shield buff but we definitely
don't need it right now yeah use that G
to slight nerve to fire rate what still
looks hot
still sounds cool rodeo three Titans
another challenge
get those challenged you know I gotta
find out I think the I think all of your
experiences associated just with this
mode oh nice one you [ __ ] idiot oh my
language great getting real hot here
respawn hey comma game box there you go
Rob my boy you got this
has he just start killing they don't
know what they're they're fine
everyone's fine I tripped and who it was
it was like I was kind of wound up and I
tripped and I threw it on a rock oh
don't stop laughing everyone stop
laughing stop laughing
how do i how do you put out a fire is a
good question I don't know got a throb
he's just bathing in it 9 o ve or
Stuart's this is not the only map for
this no there's five maps for bass could
I code I'm bored based code I war games
rise Blackwater Canal
they're currently testing additional
maps one and we'll add more in the
future
classic music option will unlock 10 vol
1 lobby music and frontier defense music
when ten matches affront food defense to
access that and then there's a new mat
yeah of course the new map was rise
which is we're on that earlier we
survived that one that one got real
hairy yeah the sound effects it the DLC
has are a drop is available ps4 Xbox one
and PC play that now japw nineteen seven
nine eight sorry unfortunately this is
gonna be our last match so we won't be
able to co-op with any of you guys but
we really do appreciate you guys wanting
to play with us maybe we'll try to do
something like that next time well we
know it can be a co-op mode
oh no upgrade court but you're good
you'll get shield back or something yeah
oshi it says nuance oh this guy this guy
Gorch public or CH oh just makes you
think Papa Roach cut my little like oh
my god
those guys are new guys so don't go in
for that thank you I keep forgetting to
look at that really authors they're all
all newts
yeah and Newtons they're trying to stop
me yeah they are
I guess that would be the one bad thing
about one hour here is that like there's
a lot of these this is legion region
with uh kind of like that nuke
now ferrari all the legions have been
new ruin your fun we need some Papa's
porches and yeah it isn't possible to go
to as an execution on those guys later
Adam Lyra that's it that's all she wrote
did it perfect timing up he's not tea
bagging with you ain't havin it oh it's
a Titan it's Auto tight that's why it
makes sense oh yeah let's go there is uh
let's see let's see let's see come on
give that home yeah Rob only likes
homeland security uh that's that's his
uh
not his day job his night job I guess
but uh yeah that was titanfall
- free dlc Operation frontier shield
available on all three platforms I'm
Eric that's Rob Rob thanks for playing
today
hide that score why I don't know ward
score I got zero
you really didn't support the team but
yeah thank you guys in YouTube twitch
games watch happening you guys so much
for watching would you appreciate it
remember every day at 11 a.m. we are
alive tomorrow we will have the lobby
hit that like follow subscribe button if
you haven't already so that you guys get
informed as to when we go live and also
for that cool VOD content I'm sure we're
gonna have some time for all T stuff go
up and yeah thank you guys so much for
tuning in and see you guys next time
thanks Rob
thank you Eric thank you so much thank
you guys have a great rest of your day